Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
Uh first of all, please mute yourself
during the talk. But if you have
question, you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A uh session at the end. Second,
today's uh DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. Uh therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed. So,
please watch out. Uh finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. All right, that's
about it. Now, let me briefly introduce
our speaker today. It is an honor to
host Singu who is a professor in the
department of applied mathematics at the
University of Washington. She also holds
an adjunct professorship in the William
Boeing Department of Aeronautics and
Astronautics. Dr. who earned her PhD
from the University of Wisconsin
Medicine in 2011 and was a post-doal
fellow at the University of Texas Austin
from 2011 to 2014.
Prior to joining uh University of
Washington in 2021, she held positions
as a assistant and later as an associate
professor at Purdue University. Our
research primarily focuses on developing
efficient structure preserving numerical
methods for multiscale kinetic equations
applied to various science and
engineering fields. Today Ching which
will um talk about very exciting topic
structure preserving particle method for
collisional plasma.
Well, um before I pass the button to
her, let me ask a somewhat informal
question if it is okay with you,
Jingway.
>> Yep.
>> Um okay, cool. Um nothing special. Um
how did you get into this applied math
computational science field? What what
draws you into this field?
>> What brought you know I my bachelor
degree is in computational mathematics.
So it's already kind of along that line
right and uh and then I decided to to
come to the US for PhD and since then I
have been working on the kinetic theory
uh and uh numerical simulation of
kinetic problems. So and now this plasma
uh is is a really exciting uh
application field of kinetic theory. So
um
>> so
>> and and
>> so when you are young you you were
already math oriented science oriented I
guess
>> uh I would say math
>> math okay
all right
>> but now it's more yeah it's I guess it's
more science oriented right it's science
driven
>> science driven
>> using using mathematical tools
>> yeah well um yeah engineering and
science you know
>> yeah engineering and science I mean the
real problem that's bring us to Yeah.
Well, thank you. Well, uh the stage is
yours.
>> Okay. Thank you, Yansu, for the kindly
invitation and the introduction. Uh
thanks everyone for coming. So, I don't
really see the participants list and
also the chat box. Uh so, if you have
any questions during my talk, just uh
feel free to interrupt me. So, um I
realize this is a data driven seminar.
So my topic here is not really data
right uh but uh it it is very important
uh uh uh to uh uh physical simulations
and in fact I believe the method
developed here has a great potential to
be used in uh many datadriven
applications. Um so uh my goal here is
to uh develop a particle method for the
plasma dynamics uh especially to include
the collisional uh effects and in
designing these methods we strive to
stra uh to preserve the structure uh in
the system. All right. So here's the
agenda of my talk. Um so I will start by
describing uh the governing equation uh
for the plasma system the so-called vest
of Maxwell Landal uh uh equation and
then uh discuss the numerical challenge
and then the goal of this work. So in
fact the uh designing a structure
preserving particle method for this
whole big system is not easy. So it uh
takes several steps. So uh so uh because
of that I'll break uh uh my talk into
three parts. So I start from the
relatively simple specially homogeneous
case which means we only focus on the
collisional part of this system and then
we'll uh combine that generalize that to
the full specially inhomogeneous uh uh
case to get a particle method. Uh but
with that it's not uh the end of the
story right once we have the particle
system uh we need still need to do time
matching. So time discretization turns
out to be super important also uh to
preserve the overall structure. So the
third part will concern the time uh
discretization and then I'll show uh
some numerical results and give some uh
uh conclusions.
All right. I believe in this audience
perhaps this I don't need really need
this introduction slide but uh let me
just uh uh quickly uh uh uh uh describe
what is plasma right. So plasma is the
false state of matter. Uh you can view
it like uh like a a system of many
particle uh uh sorry system of uh large
number of particles. Uh but these
particles are charged particles such as
ions and electrons. You can find plasmas
in nature. They are abandoned. Um but
you can also create them uh artificially
uh by heating neutral gas right uh and
all subjecting it to a strong
electromagnetic field. uh uh um study of
plasma uh is very important uh these
days and because uh they they have the
huge potential uh to uh for the design
of energy generation devices uh such as
fusion reactors.
Okay. So we are interested in describing
the kinetic uh description of uh of
plasmas. So here uh a model that is
often regarded as the first principle
physics uh is this so-called valass of
Maxwell uh Landal equation. So the basic
unknown here uh is f which is the uh I
I'm showing here only the single species
model. Of course the full model can be
mat species. So here f is uh describes
electron uh distribution um and depends
on time t uh position x and the velocity
uh v. So f lives in the sixdimensional
phase space. So the left hand side of
this equation uh we have the transport
term and we have the forcing term which
is Lawrence force and here this E and
the B uh are electric and the magnetic
fields uh these can be given externally
all determined uh self-consistently via
the Maxwell equations. uh once I say
self-consistently because the max
equations and uh the kinetic equation
actually coupled because we have this J
and row uh in the Maxwell equations
these are the current density and charge
density which are the moments of F right
which is uh obtained from the uh
velocity equation and finally the right
hand side of this equation describe uh
the collision uh effects in the system
um um and Q is a so-called Landal uh
collision operator. Uh as we will see in
more detail in next slide, this is a
nonlinear uh integral differential
operator uh that models uh the column
collisions between charged particles and
you can derive this uh this operator
from the Boseman collision operator. So
Boseman operator describe the neutral
gas uh collations. But here for plasma
since particles are charged. So uh one
need to consider this uh disgracing
limit when all the collations uh the
scattering angle uh uh uh uh becomes
zero.
Okay. Um
so since my talk the major part of of
this work concerns about the collision
so I need to dive into a bit detail on
this operator. So as we see on the
screen so this Q the Localation operator
is the integral uh differential operator
and it's nonlinear because we see 2 F
here so it's actually quadratic operator
and a here is a matrix uh the kernel uh
is a semi-possitive definite matrix
given by this form uh where this gamma
is a parameter that ranges from -3 to 1
and in particular gamma equal to -3 uh
describes a cool collisions. Um right so
as we as it's written you see uh uh this
operator in fact only uh acts in the
velocity space uh which means the time
variable and the spatial variable x just
act like parameters. Um if this
formulation looks too complicated in
fact another way to view it is to break
it into a clear gun part. So here if we
focus on the gain term and we see the
integral is with respect to v star. So
it can pull out this gradient f and then
define the rest by this uh a subf which
is a matrix. Then you see this gain term
is nothing but a variable coefficient
diffusion uh term. And similarly for the
last term if we factor out this f which
is independent of the integral and call
the rest this little f which uh little a
subf which is actually a vector. Uh then
you see this last term is a drift term
right convection term. Uh so due to this
structure a lambda operator is often
also called the focal plank operator
because you see it's just a diffusion uh
uh uh convection diffusion operator
and um another uh uh equivalent way of
uh writing this lambda operator in fact
uh which is also super important for our
later uh uh method development is this
so-called log form. Um so this one uh on
the bottom of screen is exactly
equivalent to the top one. As we see if
we take the gradient of log f we get
grad f divided by f that cancel with one
f here which gives me the gain term
here. And you can do the same thing for
the loss. Uh this way this log form uh
is most symmetric and in fact uh based
on that one can easily derive a weak
form from which all the nice properties
of this uh this operator follows. Um so
the weak form is the following.
Basically you take a test function phi
uh multiply it uh to your calculation
operator and uh integrate in v and do
some integration by parts and
symmetriization technique you can get
this long integral but from here you see
uh if we pick the test the function phi
to be a proper rate functions for
example if fi if we pick uh phi to be
constant then taking gradient certainly
this term is zero then we get a
conservation of mass and If we take phi
to be v uh a linear function right and
then taking the gradient uh this gives
me the same constant right here and
here. So again you get zero. So that's
uh use uh momentum consolation. Finally
if you take phi to be v squared uh then
taking the gradient this becomes v minus
v star. So one important property
perhaps it's not immediately uh clear
but I can tell you this uh V minus V
star actually lies in the kernel of this
matrix A. So which means again when it
hits by this kernel A uh you have zero.
So this way uh we can show the
conservation of mass momentum and energy
and one can also take the test function
phi to be the log f then we have another
same term here and since the matrix a is
semi-positive definite then we know the
entire thing is always less than equal
to zero and with a bit more work you can
show that uh this max uh this equality
sign is obtained if and only if uh the
distribution function f itself becomes
gian or boseman maxual boseman
distribution. So these are all about
local properties of the collision of the
lambda operator and in fact based on
this one can easily derive the global
conservation. So for the full veloas of
lal system uh you can derive the global
conservation of mass momentum energy and
also the entropy decay.
Okay, that's a brief description of the
underlying uh uh uh equation and we see
uh this is a huge system right very high
dimensional so six dimension plus time
um so due to that uh in fact to solve
the uh uh the plasma uh uh kinetics the
most popular method is the particle in
cell uh method. So in a nutshell uh this
method uh looks to approximate your
distribution function f as a sum of
directs right this n is a total number
of particles wp is a particle weight xp
is a particle position and vp is a
particle velocity and in fact uh if we
don't uh uh care about the collation if
we just look at the left hand side this
veloc equation uh in fact it's a
hamiltonian system uh uh so it's
conservative so so it's easy to see that
uh uh you can solve that equation u by
tracing uh the characteristics then uh
uh this naturally lead uh to uh a
coupled od system um so basically
Newton's second law right the derivative
of position gives you velocity and uh
the acceleration is given by this
laurren pausing term where this e and b
uh this uh electric uh magnetic fields
uh are determined by solving uh the
Maxwell equations on a mesh. So you have
to uh uh constantly uh uh swap between
particle uh particle locations and and
also uh the mesh uh values. Um so this
is quite natural if we just want to
solve the velocity equation without
collisions and in fact it's a gold
standard I would say in today's large
scale uh plasma simulations and uh and
then the whole thing just becomes
solving this uh this OD system coupled
with field equations. Uh one can do that
carefully to preserve the conservation
properties.
Um but now the question is what if we
want to include the collisions right
coolum collisions this is a integral and
important aspect of plasma dynamics
especially when the plasma is a dense
and also if you are close to the uh the
the fusion device the collision becomes
important um but they are often
neglected due to their high complexity.
uh nevertheless there are some uh widely
used collisional algorithms in the
field. Uh mostly so both of them uh I I
characterize them into two uh classes
but both of them are statistic nature
Monte Carlo method. Uh so typically the
way to add collisions to uh this uh p
simulation is to add them as a second uh
or separate step via time splitting.
Basically you solve uh uh your your uh
uh classical P right so you use uh
advance that by say time some time stack
and then you uh only add the collation
uh effect and then you alternate um so
there are several issues with this right
uh first of all uh both of these methods
are statistic nature so inevitably
introduce stat uh statistical noise uh
also uh the nice property is that you
tried hard to preserve right in this
collisionless PE uh is not necessarily
guaranteed right to hold uh if you add
the collisions. So that motivates us to
uh to to think about okay if we can have
a particle method we like p right um so
can we still based on the p um but
incorporate the colum collations uh uh
into this classical p method and uh and
hopefully to have a a structure
preserving uh particle method for the
full system.
All right. Uh uh with that so let me
first get to the relatively simple
problem. So forget about all the veloc
part right transport and the field term
just look at the lal collation operator.
How can we treat that? Uh for that I
want to uh uh digress a bit. uh just to
start uh with uh simplest possible uh
particle method that people use uh to
solve the linear transport equation and
hopefully we can uh uh uh that can
inspire some ideas. So um we so if we
want to solve say this linear transport
equation with a given velocity field U
right um just as the classical P does.
So what you do is you seek a weak
solution of this form right sum of dx
and xp is a particle location and since
this capital u is given uh so uh uh uh
it suffices to just trace the
characteristics right so dx uh pdt is
would just be given um by this velocity
field evaluated at xp simple enough
right in fact this is a decoupled od
system so you just trace each particle
individually
that's how it works uh in the first
place. Um but now if we want to extend
this kind of idea to treat uh the the
coolum collation or the lambda operator
realize that the lambda operator itself
is kind of diffusive type right is this
like a drifted diffusion operator. So
the first question, so before we get to
that, the first question we ask ourself
is okay, can we use this similar
particle idea to treat the heat
equation, right? Which is just simple
laplashian operator. So if we can treat
that, maybe there's a hope uh uh to
treat the L down. Um but this is kind of
counterintuitive, right? Because uh a
particle method is good uh for
hyperbolic problem but not for parabolic
problem, right? for diffusive type. Um
but okay, we'll see a way to get out of
this is to try to interpret this
diffusion operator right into a
transport form. Then we can still sort
of trace the characteristics
and in fact uh early in ' 90s uh people
already uh proposed idea of doing this.
Um so the way to achieve that is just
one critical uh uh uh reformulation of
the laplashian operator. So the great
laplash and u in fact can be
equivalently written in this way right
using the log uh u right you can easily
verify they are equivalent but formally
you see once we write it in this way uh
this is a transport equation it's just
your velocity field is nonlinear it
depends on your solution right it's
given by negative grad log u so this can
already give us some sort of idea of how
to use particles but one more thing we
need to resolve is since u the solution
itself is approximated by a sum of dx so
log of u is not well defined right so
you have to smooth it or regularize it
uh so a natural way to do it is just to
pick some kernel uh generally uh you can
you can for example you can pick gian
kernel and to modify uh uh your uh your
data function right and then this u
subron is well defined then you can take
the log and you can take the gradient
And that gives you a well definfined
velocity field. The previously described
the particle method can just apply. So
uh this is certainly uh one way to do
it. And then recently popularized I
guess by this optimal uh transport
business people realized okay in fact
you perhaps you can do better uh to to
maybe also preserve some kind of entropy
structure or variational structure in
this equation. So that's just need one
more step. So based on this uh uh
formulation of the heat equation if we
further so what is log u log u is
nothing but the first variation of the
boseman entropy. So Boseman entropy is
this hu defined here. So the integral of
u log u uh if you take the the
variational derivative of that uh you
get log u uh plus some constant. Since
you take the gradient anyway the
constant doesn't matter right? So these
two are equivalent and this motivates uh
us doing okay we can regularize
everything at the level of this logu but
we can also regularize things at the
level of the entropy right that
hopefully presumably can lead to a
better structure preserving method. Um
so if we regularize this h namely we uh
get into this log u in the definition of
the entropy then we have h uh regularize
the entropy and taking the uh variation
of that and then the gradient that also
defines uh velocity field and why this
is possibly a better approach right
because uh you regularize things at the
level of entropy. Now if you take the
time derivative of this regularized uh
entropy and this is a simple uh uh uh
algebra and uh then you plug in so
partial tu is given by your equation now
is a regularized uh hier.
Now if I do integration part um I have
this nice uh quantity which is always
less than equal to zero. So in fact this
suggests that uh that if we regularize
things at this level at entropy level we
may uh uh preserve the entropy
structure.
Okay. Now we know how to uh deal the uh
uh the heat equation. And if we go back
to the lambda operator luckily we are
not so uh off right so far away from it.
Uh remember the lambda operator has this
log formulation. Um and uh and that has
two f here but one f does not depend on
the integral. So you can put it out that
exactly gives me this nice transport
formulation of this operator. And for
the velocity field it also has this log
f same as the heat equation. Right? So
now why not we do the same thing. So if
we regularize uh the again here in this
context is the same entropy uh is the is
both my entropy. So if we regularize
this h uh uh and then taking the first
variation and taking the uh uh the
derivative the gradient that gives me a
regularized uh velocity field. Right? So
this is the basis of how to uh treat uh
this this lambda operator uh in a in a
particle formulation. And now if you're
curious about how this works. So
basically we go back to this uh uh um uh
particle approximation of f then you
substitute this f into your velocity
field regularize the velocity field. we
can easily get this nice uh particle uh
uh uh uh form for the velocity uh uh uh
field.
Okay. So that is how we do uh the
spatially homogeneous uh um uh landal uh
uh equation.
If we get back to the food system, let's
see if we can use that method directly
or there are any new uh additional uh uh
difficulties. So this is again uh uh the
same equation we saw at the beginning
right the blast of equation on the left
and uh with the l operator on the right
and in the full uh system now we have
both velocity particle velocity and the
position
and we want to trace the characteristics
right inspired by the what we did in the
homogeneous case uh we know okay this
langal operator serves kind of like a
opposing term right to update your
velocity. So it should be uh something
added here. However, once we get to this
specially inhomogeneous case um we we we
we don't see immediate generalization of
that because now uh everything depends
on the uh the physical variable and uh
the XP and VP they are a pair right
associated to one particle. So it's not
clear how to regularize this specially
dependent LO operator um uh um in this
uh in this setup. So it took us some
time uh to realize okay in order to
adopt that idea to this food system
especially in homogeneous case we have
to do some uh further work. So basically
based on our original trul operator we
need to introduce some uh uh
regularization uh in the physical space
as well. So here this sh is a kernel uh
I use uh in the in the physical space
and then since uh the original lambda
operator is specially uh how to say so x
is like a variable right everywhere is
evaluated at the same x but that is not
compatible with this particle
formulation so we have to assign a new
particle location here so basically uh
here I we insert xstar and then do
additional integral in XAR and the
corresponding entropy functional in this
case uh with the presence of the uh the
physical variable is actually a double
integral of the Boseman uh entropy uh
where you regularize this uh uh
distribution function with both one
kernel in the velocity space and one
kernel in the physical space. So this is
like a double convolution and basically
the idea here is okay we cannot allow so
it's it's it's impossible to find two
particles with the same physical
location right same position so we have
to first at a spatial point x we have to
first localize particles to a
neighborhood of this x and then within
this neighborhood deoize the physical
space right uh to allow all the
particles to to collide uh to uh
influence each other and regarding the
type of the kernels since later on we
want to use this in conjunction of the
classical pick it's natural to pick the
kernel in the physical space to be the
bspllan which is a commonly used the
kernel there um uh for one thing yeah
just be consistent with that and also
since bllan is locally compactly uh
supported which can presumably save some
computational cost later on when we
compute the velocity field and uh and
and for this velocity space kernel you
can either use bplan or gshian kernel.
Okay. Now uh everything is set uh I want
to final uh like put up this slide right
to write down the formula in case you
are interested. So with this new
regularized velocity field basically it
serves like effective force right either
the trial velocity update and this
velocity field big velocity field it's
not cheap right it's involves several
sums uh is given by this uh uh this
summation and where uh inside uh this
bracket we have uh this uh uh gradient
of the variation of entropy which is
explicitly uh computable. So it's given
this formula.
>> All right. Um but why this new particle
method can't preserve the pos uh uh
properties of the operator, right? So I
haven't really question.
>> Sure, please.
>> Yeah, on the previous slide um you wrote
FN is this mified thing and so I assume
the dynam particle dynamics are in this
modified these modified kernels. So this
f_sub_2 yes it's used when you define
this entropy part
>> right
>> but in fact yeah when you when you uh uh
approximate this velocity field for this
f you still use sum of dx so that you
can uh get this summation
>> I see because otherwise you would lose
some sort of geran property when you
move from what right
>> the okay good thank you
>> yeah it's only used to make sense of
this entropy part yeah Um yes. Now
moving a bit further uh to just to make
it um uh uh clearer right why this uh
this uh regularized particle methor
preserve the property in fact it all
lies in this discrete sort of discrete
weak form of the collision operator. So
for our proposed velocity field if you
take a test function fi uh and then uh
do a summation right in particles and
you can do this similar trick like
symmetriization and to get this weak
form. It's similar to the integral the
continuous formulation I presented
earlier but this is the basis to allow
you to achieve all the properties. Uh so
if you pick five so remember we already
take out one uh derivative uh by doing
the integration parts. So this here the
test function is really the derivative
of the collision invariance 1 b and v
square. which is 01 and VP which
corresponds to mass, momentum and energy
and due to this structure uh uh uh we
can easily see this is zero and for the
entropy uh you just pick five to be
consistent to what's appearing here then
you get the right sign. So the entropy
uh also um uh uh always uh less than
equal to zero. Okay. So that concerns uh
the the collision part right it's
actually uh we we interpret the
collision as kind of bossing term so
that they can be treated in the same
ground as the way you treat the Laurens
force. So we have this semidiscript
particle method now for this full velo
of uh Maxwell Landal system. So provided
you solve the malro equations properly I
mean this is standard in pic community
uh say if you do e lattice uh this
scheme can conserve the total energy uh
of the system
um but now we want to move a bit further
right because obtaining this partic
semidiscrete particle method is not
everything we still need to advance in
time in fact in our early experiments we
just do forward all stacking just
because this collision part is so
expensive we don't But we cannot afford
any implicit uh discretization. So we
just do simple explicit time stepping
and the conservation property is is very
bad. So that lead us to uh to think okay
can we design a time discretization
uh uh scheme right for this whole system
so that the entire uh uh uh scheme is
energy conserving. Um before I move
further I would say we we do have a
solution. Uh if you want to do go
implicit right uh you can for example
implicit may point or trapezoidal rule
um even with the collation uh one can
argue uh easily the energy conservation
however this is not a feasible method at
least for the moment for us um uh uh
just because collisions is just very
expensive and uh we want to treat it
explicitly.
So with that uh we want to think about
uh a proper uh structure preserving time
discretization
and we are actually motivated by this uh
simple uh olaren energy conserving
olaren type scheme. Uh it looks a bit
busy but basically you just do a forward
ola step for half time step to get a
prediction and then it's basically like
explicit midpoint rule and use the
predicted value FAR to get the uh uh the
chart current density jar and discretise
your field equations by midpoint rule
and finally using this FAR uh uh as like
a midpoint prediction um to do a full uh
uh like uh like uh midpoint explicit
midpoint. So um the the the scheme is
implicit but the impliciteness only
appears in the field equations and in
fact uh uh the scheme is fully explicit
if you don't have magnetic field. uh and
you can easily show this scheme
conserves the energy um which cons
consider uh contains this consists of
this kinetic energy and also the
electrical and magnetic energy.
So the first question we ask ourself is
okay in the alarm framework you have
this nice energy conserving uh time
discretization scheme can we translate
that to the particle framework to get
energy conservation right so that lead
to our first attempt uh for simplicity
let me for the moment I neglect this uh
B uh uh magnetic field for simplicity
but our scheme can be generalized to the
electromagnetic field uh electromagnetic
So basically we do also a half time step
just forward Ola right uh for this uh
system to get the prediction XAR and V
star and use that we can define uh uh um
the the the predicted right uh current
charge current density and then uh we
discretize the ampere equation yeah
using this midpoint rule and finally we
do a full uh uh like explicit in my
point right uh particle push to get x
and plus one and uh wn plus one but
however life is not that good right so
it's not that easy uh once we do this
simple uh uh uh uh translation we
realize we don't really get energy
conservation but we are not too far off
so uh this slide is a bit busy but let
me work with you so basically you take
your the last line of your scheme
and do the difference of VN plus one and
VN and dot product that with VP star
which is a predicted value at half time
step and then use your scheme. Plug
everything here and here comes the
important step because the way we treat
our collisions is uh structure
preserving is I mean conserves energy
right remember the previous weak form we
satisfied. So once you dot product this
v with your velocity field with your
collision term you get zero. So this
term does not give you any trouble. And
then uh for the rest it's a standard uh
calculation. So you plug in uh the
formula for this electric field using
this kernel on the on the mesh and uh
it's a simple algebra. And finally this
lead you to this uh nice form right you
see this is just a difference of the
electric energy over two time step.
However if you look at where we start
with so this one is not quite what we
like. If this this can be equal to the
difference of the kinetic energy then
combining everything we just get energy
total energy conservation
right and this motivates us uh to do a
further prediction right so we still
based on this scheme but however we do a
further prediction on this uh uh v plus
one as little as possible such that we
can satisfy this equality
so that gives us this proposed scheme.
Uh I skipped some detail but basically
you solve optimization problem with the
constraint uh like this. Uh so you find
this VP N plus1 as close as possible in
L2 norm uh to this VP dagger. So WP
dagger is what we obtained by the
previous uh uh simple uh translation of
the aren and then we do we correct that
with this factor gamma and you can
verify uh the such obtained uh uh vm
plus one satisfy this uh this local I
mean uh equality that we need on the
particle level.
But of course whenever we do some
correction even though here you see the
nice thing about it is we correct uh
this at the particle level we don't
correct it at a global level. So that is
uh in fact an important property. But
you may also ask when you correct this
in a brute force way can you still
guarantee the accuracy right? Because
without this correction um we know this
is second order time discretization and
what's with with the correction can you
make sure this correction uh does not uh
affect overall accuracy that's an
important question we need to address
otherwise this is not a viable approach
right so in fact uh we can show um so we
can argue
uh uh the the magnitude the the of of
this correction um to the following. So
we want to show because the overall
scheme is second order in time. So we
want to argue this correction is just
not too far away from one right up to
order uh data tq. And looking at this
correction formula clearly vp dagger uh
difference between uh between vp dagger
and vpn since this is just simple
onestep uh uh uh advancement. So their
difference is dirty. We don't do
anything sophisticated on that. But if
we look at this second this term in the
numerator and uh do some algebra using
the scheme in fact in the end you can
write it into the sum of two parts and
remember this en so is basically your
electric field at uh uh tn and this en
uh uh plus one is is is a prediction at
half time step. So their difference is
order data t right and similarly for the
velocity field you see uh the difference
between vpn and vp star is also order
data t together this gives you order
data t squared and then uh uh combined
with order data t uh you see the overall
uh uh correction is only order data t
cube perturbation to one and I should
mention um yeah so this correction is
certainly done at the individual
particle level and in practice uh we
found that this value gamma can become
imaginary for some particles. So for
those particles no correction is made.
So we just set this gamma to be one. So
in order to not break the overall uh uh
accuracy of the scheme
um so this is already a good step. In
fact, we are not quite satisfied with
this order 30T cq uh perturbation. We
wonder uh if we can do better, if we can
make that even smaller and uh and in
fact uh we were able to do it and uh the
detail is not that important. All we
need to do is to insert some additional
lines to this scheme to do a further
correction on the electric field. The
key is the following. with those extra
steps um you can still do the same uh
correction uh formula is the same. Okay.
Um but now if you get into uh this first
term in the numerator you see it becomes
the following where this right part
right this e star star is in fact a
predictive value at half time step uh of
the electric field then basically this
gives you a better uh accuracy it's all
data t squared and similarly um uh we
can boost uh the the accuracy uh for the
uh uh um for the collision part also to
a delta t squared together we boost uh
this uh um correction term to order
delta t to the power 4 and due to the
time constraint I don't want to uh
discuss the electromagnetic field but in
our paper uh we do have uh this scheme
written down and the full scheme is
almost explicit so the particle push
part is explicit except the the the uh
the field sal is implicit similar as the
alarm scheme.
All right. Um so
>> are you going to show that which paper
you're talking about?
>> Yes. Yes. I'm going to show some
references in the end.
>> Yes.
>> So uh let me jump to the numerical
results. I want to start with just some
uh uh qualitative results because uh I
guess searching the literature not much
uh uh results really about uh what
happens if you add collision to your
system. Um so the first one I want to
show is this so-called wable
instability. So we initialize the plasma
uh in the following way. uh so the uh
magnet so the electric field is set to
zero and the magnetic field is uh is
very small has a very small perturation
and um we uh the physical domain we
choose 32 gray points and in the
velocity domain I should mention we
don't need the mesh we only need this
mesh to determine the modification
parameter so the actual uh code does not
need mesh um and then we use uh this
many particles per cell and uh uh to do
the random sampling for initialization
and time step.1 simulated to uh uh 125
final time. So um first of all I'm going
to show the result. This is a a plot in
the velocity domain because it's 1D2V u
without collision. So sorry C is a
collision strength. It should really be
mu. Uh so without collation you start
off with two gausians and you kind of
reach this like how to say meta stable
stability and now uh let's see what
happens if you add a tiny amount of
collision. So in fact you need this
non-dimensionalized
uh uh framework the collision strength
is just like 10 to the uh to the power
negative 4. So it's very small but for
that we already see sort of a kind of
different uh behavior right. So the
collision try to drive things in
velocity space to a uh to a gausian
distribution.
And what if now we see if we we further
increase the collision still very small.
Now you see uh in the end the the the
distribution function in uh just becomes
a single gausian due to this uh h
theorem right entropy.
All right. Um finally uh I want to show
another example to showcase the the
effectiveness of this uh global I mean
this time discretization for global
energy conservation. So I take here this
two stream instability test uh it's 1D
value and here I should say the
collision part we're not just just to
save the computational cost we are not
really solving the lal we are solving a
focal plank version of it um but it
still preserves this conservation uh
property um so this is the parameters
how it's set and the time step.1 and the
final time 50
uh so you see there are two beams in
velocity domain as a standard and a
little perturbation uh in the physical
space and here we compare with the Boris
uh val without the magnetic field is
just Boris scheme so we compare with
Boris scheme and version one is our
first version of the particle scheme
where the correction perturbation is all
dq version two is the improved version
which is supposed to give better
conservation property right the
perturbation is on the order of delta t
to the^ 4 and and this one is the same
it's just a face space plot perhaps
eyeball you don't see any uh differences
right between all the versions but I do
want to highlight the collision effect
in these tests you see the first column
is the standard one the collision list
you probably seen that in many
literature
um but uh the first the uh the second
and to the last uh column gives you the
face base plot uh with different
collision strengths. Still very small
but you see that destroys that vortex
structure uh gradually. And if we uh for
the same uh uh test case we run it to a
longer time say time uh 50 you already
see. So this is a collision list case.
We still have this vortex uh structure
but for this 0.004 collision strength we
almost see nothing right it's it's
becomes close to a gion in the velocity
domain
um and if you check the evolution of the
electric energy uh this is how they
looks like. So blue line is uh the
collisionless case and when you add the
collision actually you see how uh this
electric energy uh behaves but again at
this level all three meers perform
almost the same.
Now if we really examine uh the total
energy growth or behavior of your system
we see a difference. So the first row is
a result uh of Boris uh corresponding to
different collision strengths. So Boris
is already considered to be very good
but we know it does not exactly conserve
energy as we see here the total energy
is uh is behaves like around 10 to the
order minus five or 10 to the minus 4.
And now if you look at our scheme uh
version one you see the energy can be
kept like to the 10 to the uh negative 9
order very small already and if you use
the improved version it's further uh
decreased to 10 to the minus 12 or 10 to
the minus 11 basically close to machine
precision
and we also check the number of
problematic particles which means this
gamma correction becomes imaginary
generate and see how uh how they uh
behave. Uh version one is this top row
and version two is the second row. Uh
it's the number of problematic particles
recorded over time. Uh it's hard to see
but you can see the average problematic
uh particle numbers in version two is
certainly much uh uh uh fewer right than
version one which is what we expected
right. We designed this improvement to
uh reduce uh chance that gamma becoming
uh uh imaginary.
All right, I think uh that uh uh lead me
to the conclusion. So we introduce uh a
particle method for the veloas of
Maxwell Landal. It can be also be worked
for the focal plank case system. And the
key thing here is to regularize your
velocity field sorry your collision term
in a way that you can treat it as
effective false right to be added to the
velocity update of your uh uh pick
method. So this way uh it offers a
unified approach to handle the transport
field effects and collisions and it can
preserve the conservation and entropy
decay structure of the coolum
collisions. And furthermore we have this
uh explicit time discretization that
designed carefully uh and to preserve
the total energy of the system.
And just to echo what I said at the
beginning, I know this is a datadriven
uh uh uh seminar yet in my talk. I don't
really have much data I guess but I do
want to say um this particle method
right uh is quite simple and flexible
and they are deterministic in nature
right everything is deterministic apart
from your initialization which could be
random. Um so basically you just have
this big OD system that allow you to
model the full plasma dynamics. So I
think in this regard this can be a very
good like a baseline method that can be
used uh in uh uh in the multi uh query
tasks such as optimal control uh
infusion problems and that will be uh
something to be considered uh something
interesting to be considered uh in the
near future. So uh with that I want to
thank you for your attention and uh
finally uh I show some references on
this slide. Uh so they are listed in
this anti- chronological order. So
basically a couple years ago we first
come up with this idea for this
homogeneous landal and it took us really
some time to figure out how to do it in
the spatially nonhomogeneous case which
is turns out to be non-trivial and uh
and then very recently uh uh we uh have
this uh time uh uh uh uh discretization
scheme in this first one we did not
include a collision and recently we
realized the scheme is can be uh adapted
to also include the collision uh so that
you you also treat the collision part
fully explicitly and then to achieve the
overall uh uh energy conservation. So
that'll be all for my talk. Thank you
for attention.
>> Thank you. Thank you so much for the
nice talk.
Very nice. Very nice. um although it's
not data driven it's
you at the end um you indeed show that
you know how it can be you know you know
beneficial to use the datadri method uh
to show
>> I I think it's uh it's quite simple
right in the end it's just like OD
system and having all all the effects uh
embedded in the system right so you can
I think based on that it should be
flexible enough yeah to allow you to do
some uh some further tasks, right?
>> I I totally agree with you. Although I
have to say the derivation was that
simple.
So um I'm just um happy that we, you
know, happen to record this one and then
uh we can always go back to the the
YouTube and then um you know look into
the details. Of course, we can get the
details from your paper as well. All
right. Well, thank you so much for the
nice talk. Let's have a Q&A sessions. If
you have questions, please unmute
yourself uh and ask questions
if I Yeah, go ahead.
>> Uh this is Eric Seia. I guess
>> Hi, Rick.
>> Hi. Um I have a couple questions. Um was
this going to um does this modification
for the collisions, does that impact
Gaus's law in any way? like is it still
satisfied through the ye grids or or is
there errors in Gaus's law? Um so the
collision itself I think it it it the
way we we modify the collision does not
affect the go law but when you
discretize the system since we want to
achieve energy conservation we actually
solve the impure uh use this impure
formulation so we don't strictly uh
preserve G law
>> so oh I see so like um one thing that
people have told me in pick is that like
when you don't satisfy Gaus's law it's
like leaving little particles behind
Um, and so then you have these things
and there's within a year there's no way
to clean that out. And so do you have a
sense for if that can be addressed?
>> Uh,
yeah. I don't know exactly what you are
referring to. So, so I I
but I I I I think maybe just based on my
basic understanding I think the
collision part is separate uh from that
issue. So um
>> okay
um and then I guess I wanted to ask is
there what is the sensitivity to the
mullification parameter?
>> Um
yeah it's tricky. It's tricky.
I have to admit that. Uh um but now what
we do is yeah we basically pick a sort
of mesh although we never need a mesh in
the actual simulation but we pick a mesh
and that determine uh the great size in
velocity uh domain and which uh gives us
this right to be used in the
modification but how to choose that and
how to choose the number of particles
per cell I don't have a good uh um way
but for the specially homogeneous
problem because it's relatively simple
only so you only treat the collision and
if you do deterministic initialization
there I have a better idea of how to
pick the the the modification parameter
>> right thank you nice talk
>> thank you
>> okay Andreas you want to unmute yourself
and ask question
>> hi very nice talk I I have a a naive
question maybe I misunderstood but are
you uh what your scheme does is are you
effectively sacrificing momentum
conservation for energy conservation or
are you conserving both momentum and
energy?
So there are several things right. So
concerning the ve uh the collision part
we are not stat sacrificing anything for
the collision part the way we treat the
collision indeed conserves mass momentum
and energy. It's only for this full
system when we want to uh add time
discretization uh we don't have a way to
preserve simultaneously momentum and
energy. So we choose to preserve the
energy.
>> Thank you.
Thank you Andreas. Uh Zena do you want
to unmute and ask question?
>> Hi Jing. Thank you very much for the
nice talk. Um so I was wondering if when
you use the log form for the collision
operator. Is that something that can
also give you a benefit if you were to
use a continuum kinetic method not just
a particle and cell or is it primarily
useful for particle and cell?
>> That's a good question. So I think
people are exploring well perhaps not
for the l but for focal plank say dert
uh uh operator you can also write it
with this log formulation. Um so I think
formulating it that way offers uh uh
alternative of viewing this operator as
a transport type uh operator right so
then if you are using olar type method
you can use hyperbolic type uh solver to
treat that problem uh while if you uh
view it like really like diffusion type
operator then what you use is I guess
more parabolic type equations. So but in
the end the the behavior of focal plank
or langa operator is really like a
combination of diffusion and advction
right so it's a competition so you have
a diffusion you also have uh uh uh uh uh
convection so it's hard to say which
formulation so either hyperbolic solver
or parabolic solver so which one is
better so I guess it's really really
depends on your specific uh uh setup
>> I see and and also I guess a related
question if you were to look at the bolt
man operator does the log form can you
put it into any sort of log form that
would give you an advantage or is that
just too complicated to deal with?
>> Sorry, you mean Boseman?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, in fact that's a that's a
that's a great question in my mind if I
for some time I don't know how to adapt
this idea to the Boseman case because
Lan operator naturally has this
transport and discreant which allows you
to formulate in that way. However, the
Boseman operator is only integral
operator, right? There's no gradient.
Although recently in mathematical
community, people try to interpret
Boseman as a gradient flow. So, I guess
it's possible uh technically speaking,
but that gradient that metric is very
strange. Uh I I don't I don't see a way
to use it for numerical computation. So,
so I don't know.
>> Okay.
>> It would be nice to have a deterministic
particle, right? analog of this for the
Boseman. Um, but I at this point I don't
know how to do it.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Uh, Zena. Um, Ichan, do you
want to unmute and ask your question?
I I see you're unmuted, but we don't
hear you somehow.
Um,
>> I don't hear. Um,
Ching, do you hear?
>> No.
>> Okay. Well, hopefully each can fix the
problem. Uh, let's move on to Janice.
You're on mute and ask your question.
>> Thank you for very nice talk. I was
wondering uh if all these uh properties
uh also hold very well if you have
varying macroparticle weights or if
you've done any tests uh with strongly
varying macroparticle weights.
>> No, right now we are doing a uniform
weight just like random sampling uh for
all particles. Um but for the uh for the
specially homogeneous case we we indeed
tried the for the determinist
deterministic sampling uh uh we we put
different weight uh on particles and
that work well but I I uh for the for
this full uh uh full uh inhomogeneous
problem we haven't tried that.
>> Thank you. Mhm.
>> All right. Well, it um hopefully you fix
your
sound problem.
Um I guess not yet. Okay, Gina, you you
raised your hand again. So,
>> yeah. Yeah. Sorry, I have another
question. So, it's related to um you
know, energy conservation. So the idea
behind getting you know mass momentum
energy conservation is you know you get
better physical fidelity right but I
guess what I'm wondering is you know you
still have a second order method uh
typically in pick for example so your
error is still somewhere and so do you
know exactly where it is because when
you don't conserve those quantities you
can sort of you know have a measure of
you know where's my air physically
speaking how much can I rely on
Whereas uh if you are perfectly
conserving these things, you know, do
you know where the error is?
>> Yeah, that's a great question that
relate to the choice of parameters,
right? So so like I said to be honest
now uh in this uh full p simulation we
we we are not quite sure how to set
choose the mesh size right in velocity
and physical domain right. Um but we we
indeed carry out some convergence test
right just to quantify the error but uh
but these tests uh uh uh are restricted
to the specially homogeneous case. So if
you have any good test cases right for
the for the full inhomogeneous problem
I'll be happy to learn.
>> All right thank you. Mhm.
>> Um, okay. Let's go back to um again is
trying.
>> Hi.
>> Oh, awesome. Yeah, we can hear you.
>> Okay, that's great. Thanks, Jimmy.
That's a very nice talk. Sorry, my
laptop just crashed the moment I turn on
my video. So, I guess I'll try
video this time.
>> So, a very interesting talk. I worked on
the lambda operator before but uh the
way we are using is using stocastic
differential equation so slightly
different point of view but uh anyway I
have two questions to uh about the
collision so first have you tried to
work on uh the collision for different
species especially when you have a very
large mass ratio
>> so for that case the collision is very
difficult so how's
>> uh how does your algorithm work on that
case
>> yes that's a great question so in fact
We had paper on this multis species land
uh uh uh uh equation but although I have
to say it's only for the specially
homogeneous case but there we already
see the benefit of particle method. So
in the past I also have experience of
using grid based method to for this
multis species collection model where
like like you as you mentioned uh when
you have this large mass ratio the grid
based method really suffers unless you
do some kind of adaptive mesh right um
but particle method naturally can treat
that. So you you just pick a different
modification or regularization
parameters for different species. You
choose the them in a a proper way
because you don't need a mesh, right? So
that that issue uh can be can be treated
well. So um yeah, we have we have paper
uh uh exactly.
>> Could you talk a little bit on how you
choose your regularization parameter
when you have large mass ratio?
Yes, it's it maybe I I need to I will
get to a bit technical detail but it's
there in my paper. It's related to the
mass ratio.
>> I see. I see. Thanks.
>> I I can I can send you to the reference
if you're interested. Yes, actually it's
actually related to that. It's related
to the mass ratio.
>> I see. I see. That's very interesting.
>> It cannot be it cannot be chosen
arbitrarily.
>> Uhhuh. I see. Uh another question is
although you didn't show it in the um
presentation but I'm wondering have you
tried to compare your algorithm with
those analytical solution you know you
have two species with two temperatures
when the temperature react to the same
one you have analytical solution
available have you compared the
algorithm to that
>> it's it's it's there in our paper
>> this particle yeah
>> thanks thanks very nice talk
>> all right awesome well I guess that's it
uh for today unless you know someone
else has a you know extra questions.
One, two, three, I guess. No.
Well, thank you, Jingu, for the nice
talk.
>> Thank you, Yansu. Thank you everyone for
coming.
>> Yeah. Well, thank you. Thank you. Uh do
you mind you share the the slide with
me?
>> Uh no, I can send it to you.
>> Okay. Cool. Awesome. Well,
>> okay. That's it for today.